Peter Ducey with some questions at the
White House Press briefing let's listen
so the president has used the tools that
he has in front of him uh to uh to
prepare ahead of title 42 lifting as you
know that is happening uh in the next
couple of days and so we are putting uh
DHS Department of State is putting forth
processes processes to deal to deal with
the changes that are going to be ahead
of us and so that is what's important
here and that's what you've been seeing
for the past several months you've heard
from DHS you've heard from the state
department on what we're putting in
place to deal with to to deal with the
Border once title 42 lives you said
yesterday that when it comes to Illegal
migration you've seen it come down by
more than 90 percent where did that
number come from it was I was speaking
he was telling us the number is I hear
you I'm about to answer
I'm about to answer this year so if you
if you if The Dramatics could come down
just a little bit The Dramatics would
come down a little bit dramatic about
asking a question about okay I'm gonna
answer so I was speaking to the parolee
program as you know the president put in
place a parolee program to deal with to
deal with certain countries uh on on
ways that we can limit illegal migration
and we have seen the data has shown us
that it has gone down by more than 90
percent that was what I was speaking no
I'm we're going to go we're going to
move forward go ahead go ahead
just two quick follow-ups on the meeting
next week I'm not sure sorry
yeah one more on the um vaccine minute
being left on May 11. do you guys plan
to uh rehire anyone who was fired or
voluntarily resigned under that policy
would they get any sort of conversation
that pay anything like that like we'll
have more to share well obviously I
addressed us addressed a moment we
discussed earlier uh we're the White
House through Queen Jean-Pierre
um made the statement that the number of
people crossing the southern border was
actually down
um Peter Ducey being asked to cut The
Dramatics while he asked his questions
didn't get many did he uh the first
reporter got four and I think Peter got
two and a half
and that's where it is I'm Steve Ducey
I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley
Earhart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis